and this brings us to our friend ellen
page
i can't say that i'm gonna this podcast
is gonna be taken down if i use the
phrase ellen page
i will admit something i have no idea
who ellen page is
i wouldn't recognize her i couldn't pick
her out of a lineup i don't think i've
seen her movies
somebody told me she was an inception
and i did see that movie but i don't
remember her
i don't i haven't seen her stuff but
apparently she's a famous actress
and she was a lesbian
apparently by the way there is a
connection to ellen page
during 2015 during the run-up to the
2016 election
ellen page this very left-wing then
lesbian actress
walked up to ted cruz who also didn't
recognize her and
starts picking a debate with him about
lgbt
rights and sexuality take a list it
wasn't particularly coherent it's very
funny you can tell she's frustrated
that cruz doesn't know who she is this
was her perspective in 2015.
what about the question about lgbt
people getting fired for just strictly
being gay or trans
well what we're seeing right now is
actually
we're seeing bible-believing christians
being persecuted
so for example one of the couples
discriminating
no for living according to their faith
so for example
all right and segregation i'm happy to
answer your question but not to have a
back and forth debate
if they were murdering people it would
be wrong
but in iran and isis it is the
governmental body that is executing them
for being homosexual
and why does the obama administration
not stand against us
i don't know i would love to talk to
obama about it that'd be great well good
then we're agreed on that no well
we're not don't do that and eventually
she just sort of
walks away says listen lady you know
i've answered your questions and she
she goes away and she's obviously
dejected that he doesn't know who she is
she's no longer a lesbian so ellen page
is now identifying as elliott page which
means
according to gender ideology she has
been a man
the whole time nobody knew it she didn't
even know it but she has been a man
because she is her true self
according to this gnostic dualistic
ideology of transgenderism
whereby your body has nothing to do with
your true self your true self is this
purely metaphysical
entity she was always a man which means
because she's she was identifying as a
lesbian she likes chicks it means
that for all these years a straight
white man
has been stealing the roles of women
and lesbians that's outrageous
that's a scandal and how you know the
patriarchy
strikes again she is a straight white
male she is therefore
uh part of the problem uh
she's not a man right she's obviously
not a man she's a woman she's a actually
petite woman as you can see
in that video she's not particularly
masculine
now what is the issue here if she is a
straight white man
is she going to be castigated in the way
that straight white men are by this
left-wing culture
now there are there are actually quotas
you're not eligible for certain awards
in hollywood if you
have too many straight white men in the
in the movie so is she a straight white
man that's what she's saying she is
but not really because everyone knows
that she's a woman
and she's just identifying as a man and
she can do whatever she wants
she can do whatever she wants and it
just doesn't matter people are not going
to consider
ellen page on the same sexual
uh category as ted cruz for instance or
or as me they can do whatever they want
and i think
look we need to point out this hypocrisy
it's a big portion of this show is
identifying that but
we have to go further than that as
conservatives
we need to recognize that they don't
care if we call them
hypocrites some of them recognize the
hypocrisy most of them
don't even acknowledge the existence of
objective truth or an objective moral
standard right
one of the points of this idea that
gender is socially constructed
one of the points of this idea that
intersectionality means that only my
suffering is the
the way that i can measure moral
goodness in the world one of the points
of progressivism
explicitly is that there are no fixed
laws to the universe
the the early progressives write about
this in almost these exact words
there are no fixed laws there is no
eternally true human nature
or sexuality or whatever that everything
is evolving and changing and so they
can't
they can't be held to account for those
standards because the standard they're
fosting on us is whatever they think
whatever the party says
is right we covered on my book show at
prageru 1984
where history is always being rewritten
standards are always being rewritten
language is always being rewritten and
whatever the party says is right
now that's become cliche to invoke
but there's a reason that george orwell
saw that happening
because that that is what's happening
right now and
the the way to fight that is not just to
point out the hypocrisy the way to fight
that
is to offer our own vision of things the
left is giving people their vision the
conservatives are not giving
people our vision because we're too
afraid to make claims
about how we should live in the world
how
families should be recognized how small
local governments should be made up
the relationship between the local to
the national
how we ought to behave because we've
thrown our hands up in the air and said
you do you if it doesn't
scare the horses if it doesn't hurt
anybody else that's fine
no the reason that the left is winning
on the culture
is because people don't want that people
don't want to throw their hands up in
the air
people want a vision and conservatives
have failed to do that
[Music]
you